and then
and then on the second page uh number
two on line four
it was recommended by Mr head that we
delete that whole section too
oh what why is that
uh that's what I was looking for
um
okay that's the records
you know what I recall is that
um some of the records like for example
some of the records that schools may
have is not their records but
um
you know medical records from a medical
facility so it's not actually their
records
so for them to give that up was in
question oh okay because this is
could we possibly say that both parents
have the
uh a right to the same records whatever
right the parents have and just put your
uh speaker on yeah I don't know if we're
being televised or not
um
there's been an issue that in the past
that both parents aren't getting the
records only one of the parents gets the
record and the other one doesn't and I
didn't know if that was an attempt on
this bill to do that where it kind of
matched up that way
uh with the rest of it
uh bill
um otherwise yeah I'm not sure where
it's going
wow
so I was wondering if we could a minute
to be clear that way
okay to be cleared as far as what as far
as that we're not trying to get records
we're not supposed to have which I
really don't know what those would be
yeah but if one there if the records are
available to one parent the same record
would be available to the other parent
right there wasn't one time I know in
the past that
the you know the custodial parent when
we used to do that would get the records
but then the non-cost oil would not they
would not be available to them and then
the school said well you need to send us
your address to say the other thing
if you want them and we thought we
settled it that way but I'm I'm hearing
it didn't get settled but I thought
maybe a simple something simple in here
um
I'm trying to think of the wording
any records available for one parent
would be available to the other so so if
there's one parent that's
um paying for a psychological uh uh
you know therapy for the child the other
parent
would be able to get those records
I would think so as long unless there's
something wrong with that parent
oh you know what's the score if the
court said otherwise of course
that would be appropriate so so again
the court would be deciding we might
whether would you mind asking the
sponsor what their thoughts
I think it's
be back there
we don't have a sponsor here okay
we don't
Here Comes Here Comes information
chart of what is accessible
um for parents would you like me to
print it out real quick yeah that'd be
great helpful yeah
representative yes uh representative
thank you for taking my question this is
this bill is
this bill is on uh based on shared
parenting correct
yep so if you you're always going to
have one custodial parent so if this is
about giving shared parenting
there's always going to be a custodial
parent
correct
could be shared right but if it but if
it's shared parenting both parents
should have access to the records
correct
again that same uh
the same situation that I gave you if if
if a parent's paying for
therapy for their child
um what you're saying is that
the other parents should be able to
access those records yes and the reason
why I'm saying that is
um
like I I know of an instance where uh
the father is paying
or
the services for this child
um because the finances are a little bit
tighter on the mother's side because of
what she's carried on for her own
burdens
the father should have access to that as
well too wouldn't you say even though
the child's living with the mother and
it's she had parenting time but the
father was trying to do the the right
thing by helping extra by paying for the
services he should have access for what
he's paying for right well you should
have access for what he's paying for
yeah but right but in my scenario these
you know that one party's not paying for
it
and it and it was on one of the parties
to seek that therapy so
I don't know if the other party should
have access to those records
uh and then you look at the best
interests of the child with those
records produce
something that would make the child uh
you know anxious over uh you know saying
something you know to the therapist
about one parent or another uh would
that
this bill is is about represent
responsibilities and rights based on
shared parenting so if they're shared
doing shared parenting I think
everything needs to be shared
okay
because I have to think from the past
might be butting in on you I think I am
I'm sorry I was just going to concur
that
um unless there's an uh something in the
law that states that the parent should
not be able to access those records
whether it's 20 80 50 50 60 40 however
it's shared it is a shared parenting and
they're supposed to be cooperatively
working together as parents so I would
say it should be
um well the record should be shared I
mean we have cases where a person could
be deployed and they don't have access
to the child because they're not even
here but yet they do need to know what's
happening with the child with regard to
their medical situation so that they can
be a part of the decision-making process
yeah
um yeah I just I just warn against
um ammunition you know if there's
another parent looking for something for
ammunition you know I don't know how
that's determined
um I don't know if there should be an
intent yeah I would like I would I would
like to get you know my child help I
understand you're paying for therapy I'd
like I'd like I'd like to access those
records because I would like to help and
I don't want to duplicate it
it's all in that case yes that that
would be uh well you know as a parent
you have a right to the record yeah it
doesn't come on put your speaker on
sorry about that as a parent you have
right to record regardless who pays for
them necessarily
uh what schools public schools public
pays for schools but the records are
accessible to the parent naturally right
um now we're going down the road of this
bill and the Shared Parenting share
apparently we talk about I think mostly
it's about physical but we used to have
it divided up it was legal and it was
physical and this used to come under the
legal pad of
but again we don't do we don't do
custodial anymore we do each parent has
a certain amount of Rights and
responsibilities that's what just comes
out of the parenting plan and
uh
so we did away with that we're very
futuristic here in New Hampshire
definitely ahead of the federal
government which usually which called
people either an absent parent or they
we or they call them a non-custodial
parent and that's where the issue is
risen in the past is people just want to
be involved with their children and know
what's going on
so so shared parenting they would have
access to those records especially in
school you know if the court didn't say
you can't have access when you go to the
school and they say well you know and
there's one parent that's dropping the
child off picking a child up and the
other parent shows up
um you know you just show your dockets
and I'm you know your your uh final
order saying you have a good share
parenting I have that responsibility
and you have access to those records
I don't know yeah I don't know what you
have I I would think we would
typically in a shared parenting
situation with the schools the schools
know that there's a shared parenting
plan in place and documents are sent to
both parents all the time even all the
notices I know that when I was teaching
I would send out one to the mother one
to the father and
um they always double the communication
to make sure both parents are in the
loop
okay so so that's not at issue then uh
with respect to school uh how about
medical
oh each side of the parenting plan
already specified
okay
you're not gonna make her put a
microphone on like you made uh yeah I
should have
yeah yeah actually uh that's a good idea
actually if if uh somebody wants a weigh
in on this discussion uh clarify it for
us
okay yeah
uh Aaron Justina with New Hampshire
legal assistance um in terms of
information sharing and access to
records
um if you it's already that language is
already in uh the current parenting plan
form it's on page seven paragraph e
um and IT addresses unless there's a
court order stating otherwise both
parents so again regardless of
um what the percentage of time is both
parents have equal rights to inspect and
receive school records
um both parents are encouraged to
consult with school staff
um both parents have equal rights to
inspect and receive governmental agency
and law enforcement records both parents
have equal rights to consult with any
person who provides care or treatment
for the children and to inspect and
receive Medical Dental or psychological
records subject to other statutory
restrictions
so that that includes medical yes
medical records yes okay
and Consulting with providers as well
that both parents have access to that
under the current parenting plan
certainly uh parties if it's unsafe for
whatever reason in the uh situation you
were discussing
um representative long if there was a
concern uh for example
um a child's been abused by a parent
that there's been a finding of that and
a child in a therapeutic environment and
is talking about these issues there
could potentially I would think be some
restrictions on uh what the
the abused parent has access to just in
terms of whether or not that's in the
best interest of the child to release
that information but General languages
that both parents have equal access to
review and have access to all of those
Medical Dental psychological school
records
and that would be regardless to the
percentage of correct oh parenting
rights responsibility correct correct if
we're talking about uh parenting time as
well as decision making so residential
responsibility and decision making
whether it's joint or soul
thank you
so so I believe what the issues were
with 185
was the
um
the presumption of shared parenting
language
I believe
and also the uh I believe was there
clear and convincing evidence in here
yeah
yeah there was and so so those were the
two issues
what was the third
the third issue when we looked at this
the last time and we were looking at
when it came in again
um they wanted a definition for fit
parent because the term fit parent is
used in the bill
and we did I worked with representative
Moulton on a um
addressing those two issues there was
the fit parenting issue and then there
was another issue
um
it would have been number three
um yeah number three in section B
and we reworded that as well
um
we were proposing a rewording of that
and then the question
um that was coming before the committee
was the clear and convincing
evidence-based
um
putting that in the bill
it was um if one of the parties does not
request sole primary attorney
responsibility for the child yes and
then the part that we were changing it
said one parent lives or Works outside
the town one lives outside the child
School District or one parent is
convicted of abuse and we've changed it
to read one parent lives a substantial
distance outside the child school
district one parent is committed to
frequent
um
significant periods of time away from
home due to military or employment
obligations or one parent is convicted
of abuse or neglect
and those are all agreed upon things
between the two parents it was just the
wording that representative Moulton
wanted to do it a little bit more
defined
and as far as the fit parenting we could
not find a definition in New Hampshire
law that defined fit parent
so we looked at it was actually taken
from the dcyf motion for parent hearing
and we went by that and just basically
saying fit parent means having a present
ability to care for a child having the
basic necessities of having a home or
other shelter a means of supporting the
child whether through employment or
other income and pose no harm to the
child
the dcyf okay that came from yeah the
dcyf motion for a fit parent hearing is
where we came up where there was no
other definition in New Hampshire law so
we're in a in the original bill is uh
the reference to fit that parenting
yeah that would have been just under the
definition and I'd have to go back
through I know that came up I think it
was
um
representative Raymond is the one who um
on the on our committee who had a
question about that definition and
that's why we representative Fulton and
I uh found a way found a definition for
it
I'm not exactly sure where exactly in
the bill that the term fit parent is
used I'm sorry
okay so it's in the Sydney Amendment it
was offered to us and I don't believe
the Amendments
um
I don't believe we took the amendment up
and the full committee does anybody
remember because but it is in the it is
in the other definition of joint
parenting it's it it referred to uh with
a child by both fit parents so then we
needed to Define what is any original
oh
I apologize chairman my my um computer
went dead and I don't have my directions
to my the original oh the original for
myself
foreign
okay
so thank you for taking it uh listening
to me um Gail drobat Amherst New
Hampshire so the Supreme Court of the
United States has recognized in Troxel V
Grandville that
um
uh a fit parent to Boom hold on one
second
is Court held unconstitutional a trial
Court's order requiring a fit parent to
permit visitations with her children
grandparents the court recognized that
the United States Constitution protects
the fundamental rights of parents to
make
decisions concerning the care custody
and control over their children to
protect that right a plurality introxel
applied a presumption that fit parents
act in the best interests of their
children so parents are presumed fit
unless proven otherwise in a definition
of fit
no you're a presumed fit
yes
it's showing other ones right
so uh okay so somebody who
is substantially out of the district or
somebody who works in another state uh
they're assume fit and that doesn't
there still remain fit even if they're
substantially
on a district or work in another state
correct for Shared Parenting purpose yes
they definitely would so if I gotta get
up at 3 30 in the morning to uh be to
work for six
um and I have custody of my child I wake
up the child at three to take them
wherever I gotta take them
or if I choose
um
maybe my parents their grandparents take
care of them that's all considered fit
in in that opinion yeah why wouldn't it
yeah okay yeah definitely the question
yep definitely
um okay
and parents have the right to
make arrangements for their children if
they live a distance away I mean you
would hopefully work that out with your
other co-parent
um and when you can't you may have a
family member get your kid to daycare
like like married parents do
I mean yeah well
the divorce couples right not always
line up like married couples not always
so
okay but the parents are still presumed
fit and less proven otherwise in a court
of law
all right so
so when we go back to the original
uh can I make a comment on the records
too
Honda wreckage you were talking about
the school records and medical records
yeah parents do have the right to have
that but what's happening schools
medical they're not allowing one parent
to have that so I think it needs to be
in Statue it is in the parenting plan
but if it's not in statute why would why
would the school follow that
okay I mean I think we have to have so
we need it clarified yeah right
okay
thank you
so there's there's four actions we need
to recommend to the full committee one
is the presumption of shared parenting
um is there any discussion on that uh
yes
representative ball
yes I think that we should
the presumption of shared parenting I
think that we should just stay with the
wording as it is in the amendment that
was
um presented to us where joint parenting
schedule means approximately equal
and I think that we keep it there I
don't know I know we use the term shared
parenting throughout but we do want it
to not say presumption of 50 50 but just
the
that it means approximately equal
residential parenting okay and that's in
the um
that's a knee amended version that was
in the second that was in the last
Amendment okay so I got to figure out
I'm not sure
it was amazing I don't recall that I I
thought we looked at the amendment
because I got my red pen all over it it
was thinking it was discussed 2023 and
then it was the um zero seven five eight
H is the amendment I'm looking at that
was the last one same same here uh so
that went before the full yes it did
okay so with respect to the Joint
parenting schedule you're talking about
line five
yes it should remain that way as saying
no I don't have lines I just have the
definition
6-a correct yeah
um where it says joint parenting means
approximately equal residential
parenting I think it should remain that
equal residential parenting
responsibilities include overnights with
the child both fit parents yes okay
okay so recommend uh so we'll recommend
that
6 Dash a
remains
any other discussion on that
CNN the other
I'd like to hear potential I think it's
going to come up
why why it means to be that
what we want is the presumption correct
yeah
okay okay so you want the word
presumption in there so joint priority
schedule means
approximately equal or the presumption
of equal okay so do we want to do we
need to wear presumption in there I
don't believe so
huh I don't think we need the word a pro
I don't think we need the word
presumption because it right there tells
us that it means approximately
we're taking out I know that we had
discussed a lot when we were talking
before this went in for an amendment we
were talking a lot about a presumption
of and they were calling it 50 50 or
presumption of equal parenting but this
is actually in my opinion
um
meaning approximately equal
it's it means the same thing but we're
not trying to cut the baby right in half
there may
it might it might be 51 to 49 just the
way because every month could be a
different
day so that's what the big discussion
was how do we how do we get 50 50. it's
impossible to make sure then you'll have
somebody yeah I'm opposed to 50 50
Assumption of 50 50. right um but but I
need definition for the I mean it seems
to me that
uh the presumption word
makes me a little more comfortable
um
I I so you're saying instead of
approximately just means presumption of
equal residential
to say uh joint parenting schedule means
a presumption of equal
this
a recall parenting
this is
we've always intended and tried to do
this in the past
because we wanted a legal thing
something legal that would say you've
got a presumption that you get your
parental rights will give you 50 of the
time however that didn't mean that we
expected everyone to utilize it or even
be able to utilize it but it gave them a
uh an ability to appeal
right now there's not much of an ability
to appeal because you're you're stuck
with
presumption
and such so
that's really what we always
where we wanted to go with this
not so much to make people think they
this is actually physical it's it's more
a right
to try to utilize
legal right to utilize yeah I know this
presumption are out the window if
there's if there's an issue with uh you
know an abuse and neglect uh domestic
violence
um so those those presumptions would be
out so I don't know what protects that
you know I don't know what protects
abuse and neglect
or dimension of violence
um or a mental health issue with a
parent or a substance use issue with a
parent
under the current joint parenting
approximately equal to a presumption
that's why I thought the presumption
word being in there would
help that and it would I have to agree
so are you saying that we just put in
joint parenting schedule means a
presumption of approximately equal
parenting and just put in a presumption
of actually I I don't know what language
protects what I'm looking to protect
could you advise as to
you might have to get up there though
because I I don't know if they're
recording these or what
legal assistance
um we would be opposed to any language
regarding presumption of shared
presumption of equal or approximately
equal
we believe that the current language of
frequent and continuing contact already
that that's the starting point and that
there are then factors to consider
including whether domestic violence is
present
we feel strongly that any mention of
presumption of equal or approximately
equal or shared or 50 50 will in fact
prevent victims from coming forward
to leave a relationship because they
will feel that it is better for them if
if they know that the court is
automatically going to apply a 50 50
standard of parenting time then they
will consider that it is safer in fact
for them to remain in the home
to have eyes on the children to make
sure that the children are protected if
they know that otherwise if they go to
court that 50 percent of the time then
they will not have eyes on the children
they will not be able to protect their
children 50 percent of the time that
will be a huge barrier for victims to
leave a domestic violence relationship
so we're in strong opposition of
um moving beyond the current language
and statute which is promoting
continuing and frequent contact okay now
does the language fit parent change any
of that I mean somebody who's domestic
violence or abusive neglect on a child I
mean they wouldn't be considered a fit
parent so they wouldn't be
assumed or
um
they wouldn't be
there wouldn't be a presumption that
they'd get the equal time because then
I I haven't really thought about
defining the term fit parent I think
that that creates another set of
obstacles for a judge certainly to
consider then you're going to have
what does that look like exactly what
evidence is going to be required to
present in order to demonstrate whether
you are or are not a fit parent
um
I think the language that we currently
have in statute works it needs to be
applied consistently
um but I don't know if adding a
it's possible that adding a definition
of fit parent could create
additional issues
I don't know if it would correct the
problem
okay because a fit Baron could also
frequent or continuing contact that that
that could go to the current language
right um
okay
okay I I can't say as I agree with all
that first of all it um
it'll present now we're working with a
presumption that people with batteries
and if somebody's going to stay back
what we're looking for at least I'm
looking for is right now you're going to
court and you have zero you have nothing
then they have to build it up I'd like
to see it started 50 50. and then chip
it back and re relayer it and that's
what this we've been working on this 25
years
yeah we've made really good progress but
we haven't quite got to that
right this gives you
rights and
tells the public that we care
so so
in in that under that same uh statement
you know I'm looking for where because
when we change something I like to look
at
what's the potential of some of these
becoming conflicts you know adding
conflict to the current conflict uh
you know cases we have now
um
you know but but there's a clear
listening to testimony for all these
years there's a clear
uh frequent and or continuing contact
that's just not happening
you know so what is it that we have to
do
uh to
um
you know to make that happen
uh I think adding a fit parent
um you know not putting in the
definition is already a couple
definitions already heard that's good
enough for me
um
fit parents assume that there's no
domestic vial there's there's the
violence there's no
um abuse and neglect on a child there's
no substance or mental health
um I
so
yeah frequent or continuing contact
uh to me
seems
um
seems what the problem is
it does I hate to say that but it but it
does it does seem to uh you know because
we're hearing testimony of people that
just aren't getting the frequent or
continued contact and their fit parent
you know uh as far as I could know you
know
um not that they just tell me but you
know it seems consistent with their
testimony year after year so
uh
what do you think I agree with you
um that that frequent and continued
visits has been
a problem in the court for years I think
there is no definition of what is
frequent and what is frequent to one
person seeing their child every other
week is not frequent it's not enough to
maintain a relationship and I think the
whole point is to do what's in the best
ensure that the child and all evidence
points to having the child maintain a
relationship with both parents equally
is what is Works what works and of
course we're not talking about cases
where Devi and we have other things but
in a case where we have nothing we're
dealing with a fit parent two parents
who have always had access to their
children have been good parents that we
need to make sure that for in the
child's best interest that the
relationship with both parent continues
as equally as possible
actually could I have you sit over there
and just put the mic on I don't know
who's recording or if it's even being
recorded but
thank you
uh so if you consider those cases where
prior to the separation prior to the
divorce
the
it's possible that somebody was
traveling for work or was on the road a
lot or
um
may have been deployed uh so those
situations where they were not in the
home all of the time it wasn't 50 50. it
was it was more like a 75-25 split right
even when they were in the home
so that should that change once the
marriage ends once the relationship ends
and you're looking at two different
households what if what they were used
to Prior when the relationship was still
intact was a 75-25 split that's what the
kids are used to that's what everyone
felt good about so now they're going to
go into court and the presumption is
going to be 50 50 right which is not
what they were practicing
prior to and I suppose they could come
to an agreement and that would address
it but I think we're looking at
situations where an assumption that
everybody
wants 50 50. everybody had 50 50 when
prior to the relationship ending and
so when we use frequent and continuing
contact IT addresses
those other types of situations it
doesn't make it a standard it doesn't
make it an assumption that that's what a
family should look like that's what a
parenting a fit parent should have 50
percent you know somebody could be a fit
parent and still have 25 percent of the
time with the kiddo yeah no yeah we're
not talking 50 50.
I know the presumption of shared
presumption of shared parenting I I I'm
not looking at all at 50 50 because
you're absolutely right you know I I
could have a 60 40.
um so I would I would want that I mean
it's when I go from 60 40 and
divorce is filed and I go to zero until
things get straightened out uh you know
that that's the issue that we're looking
at so it's not a presumption of 50 50.
it's a presumption of
um you know I've shared parenting which
hysterically right which which
historically has for me has been 60 40.
I've been 40 percent
um so I I don't yeah so so if we if we
don't assume the 50 50. I think it will
be
will the equal or Price that's a
starting point right it's a starting
point that it will be equal parenting
and yes you are correct that there could
be a parent that's deployed or has that
but let's look at it this way you could
have a person that goes into the
military service at 18 and they're they
are um retiring at 38 after 20 years
their parent their children can be very
young at that point and even though they
may not have been they may have been
deployed but why would we be punishing
them now that they're no longer deployed
and that they can have a job and be
close to home and put in time with their
children
um and just because they're not at the
home does not mean they are not involved
in that child life does not mean they're
not FaceTiming that child all the time
so even though a parent may be having
employment elsewhere that doesn't lessen
the fact that they are still the 50 50
parent whether they're there physically
or not emotionally they are so I think I
agree with representative uh bigford and
we just are looking for a starting point
and if need be we we adjust that and
that's also already built in the into it
and that's why we were rewording that if
the parents agree that because of
employment far away or because of moves
that it may not be 50 50. but that
doesn't mean that when we come to
reevaluate in three years that we don't
look at the parenting plan and say well
I've moved back into the area or I've I
have retired or I've gotten a new job
and now I can be home with my children
that they should lose that opportunity
so I think it's just coming back to that
idea that what's in the best interest of
the children is as much contact as they
can have with each parent
I think that was the whole intent of
this bill like to add to that that when
we worked on a pairing plants and such
that it took years to get to that but we
said that the scenario of you know
somebody doing 60 40 whatever it was
during their marriage or whatever it was
that they were together when it comes to
go to court it's now time for reset now
we get to rearrange Our Lives to what's
going to work for our children and
families and often that means the change
of sometimes employment
sometimes a residence and that sort of
thing so yeah we want to give them that
opportunity and it wasn't happening
before that because that's what would
happen the the justices or the marital
masses at the time who just say well
this is the way it's been so that's the
way you wanted it don't Focus continue
that way
and we just need to give people the
opportunity and that and I think the
courts has made some progress right but
I also agree with the point that I'm not
sure as frequent as a defined enough
word
to go with yeah so so I mean back to the
best interest of the child I you know if
I'm if I'm 60 40 and I'm the 40 and I'm
going through a divorce and I'm gonna
and I'm looking for 50 50. uh I'm gonna
sell a 50 50. I'm gonna I'm that child's
gonna go to my mother's gonna go to my
sisters or brothers and that's
disruptive to the child that is not what
the child is used to so if we assume the
50 50 it does change the child's
um what the child is accustomed to in
the case that it's not 50 50 it
absolutely does I I believe it
absolutely does a child changes their
class in school every single year
children are the most resilient and
adaptable little human beings and so I
do disagree with you and also going back
to the domestic violence
um or that type of a situation we also
have situations where traditionally and
I I'm just going to say traditionally
fathers did not get as much visitation
because they worked outside the home and
so they got pushed into this 40 60 40
situation and quite frankly there are
many men out there and dads who have
stayed in very abusive households
because they don't want to lose access
to their children and so they keep
putting up with the abuse that they're
taking within their home so abuse goes
both ways and I think I still go back
and I say it is up to the parent it's
not just you know you're saying well
that's the way it's always been 60 40 or
I'm not home but when you're getting a
divorce and nothing is going to be the
way it's been you're probably going to
be selling your house the children are
going to get new homes everything's
going to change and I think that we have
to have the reset and say well if
everything's going to change
half that child is came from the mother
and half that child came from the father
and both parents are equally have rights
to that child to raise that child and be
a part of that child so I absolutely
agree that we must stay
that we have equal as close as possible
we start at equal parenting and unless
it's proved otherwise that is the way it
should go or unless the parents agree
yeah and I totally disagree with that so
I'll agree to disagree with that it's
not what the child is accustomed to to
your argument if there were 50 50 the
child's accustomed to that but now that
it's 60 40
the child's resilient and he could
adjust to that yeah I don't agree
um so okay so we're gonna we disagree
with that one
uh uh sure
so
um I had a husband who traveled all over
yeah could you introduce yourself oh
Lisa post I'm a representative from
lineborough New Boston and Mount Vernon
uh thank you for taking my statement
here
um first
I my husband traveled a lot and I took
care of the kids and lots of times
um when I was working I had to use a
babysitter for my kids they get used to
that my parents used to come down if my
husband was gone for an extended period
of time and they would take care of our
children sometimes his parents would
come and help us out so all those people
in their lives creates
a contact with each other that they get
used to and moving around doesn't change
that if we send them down to their
grandparents for a week in Texas
they come back happy they love it and
they they develop a relationship that
lasts a lifetime and so the same thing
happens if you get divorced you're
together and you get divorced and things
change those children have made contact
with both parents and stay in contact
with both parents they have them for the
rest of their lives and while I realize
people fight it's it's in the statistics
here that approximately equal or 50 50
or however you want to put it that's
just a Wordsmith thing but for people
who can
you know have the ability to
um have something in law where that can
say they can have equal or approximately
equal or 50 50 that gives them the
opportunity to try this and see if they
can make it work because they can always
go back to the courts but this way this
gives the family a chance to thrive for
everyone moms dads grandparents because
you know that if one if they're fighting
one won't let their child go to that
grandparent right it becomes this huge
thing and then become disconnected from
family members cousins things like that
so to keep a family together means a lot
and there is so many statistics and I
know you guys got
um
information from the National Parents
organization which gives you
the information that shows that it
children fare better parents feel
um are better because they're not
stressed out they don't have the same
kind of problems because if you have a
okay kind of a wiggle room I I have to
work late can you keep the kids tonight
all those things would happen gradually
but it usually and and in all of the
literature it shows that it's better for
all of the family including grandparents
and cousins and things like that we all
want you know our families and our
children to be the healthiest they can
be and I think whatever wording you
choose equally or approximately equal
which I think the presumption of equal
or approximately equal gives that wiggle
room but also gives a standard
right so I I mean the only thing is I'm
not willing to I'm not looking to try
anything because yes you can also always
go back to court with the child and that
the child can't doesn't have that option
uh and my primary interest is with the
child uh you know it would be great and
by the way ninety percent of the cases
work out that way it's the 10 that we're
looking to
to try to get some sensibility to right
but it is the 10 that we're talking
about in these statistics right so so
when you say you want you you care for
the child yes you do care for the child
but it's up to the parents to care for
the child so yeah and I have no control
over that
they have the soul control over that
how are you saying has that I don't have
no control over how the parents treat
each other or the child that's not in
our my control right but that's not our
job as the government we just give them
correct so that's out of my control so I
don't consider that what I consider is
the best interest of a child so we're in
these difficult cases
where is the child being harmed and
and I I don't believe that the
resilience is as big as sometimes we
think it may be uh that a child will
adjust quickly
um and it all depends where the parents
are coming from
um as to why they want this 50 50 or all
of a sudden if you if you look at all
the states that enacted this
everything went down domestic violence
reports and all of that all went down so
I think you have to consider that it
it's already been enacted in many states
some that doesn't even have legislation
but they enacted it and they are
thriving so I don't know why we wouldn't
want that to happen over uh
language that is really similarly
you know so yeah I mean we beat up this
language I I'm in opposition to the to
this everybody else is in favor of it
that's fine we'll have the debate at the
full committee level I do want to add
that we shouldn't be afraid of changing
circumstances I have uh grandchildren
that move every three to four years I
don't like that idea I hate it
but you know their dad's in the Coast
Guard and if you're in the military and
that's just Korea and they get they're
required to change with the federal
government do why can't
people do a reset themselves and and
realign their situation they have to
otherwise it's a serious problem for
uh okay parents so so as as far has the
presumption of shared parenting or the
50 50 we've discussed that where we
could just add one one last thing to
that and I think the purpose of writing
this was really to bring our courts
together and what we learned when we
visited the courthouse which was a
enlightening to me because I thought
judges all thought the presumption was
50 50. that that's how they approached
every case but come to find out the
particular judge that we met said no I
don't presume 50 50. he goes the
opposite way so what I think is we're
trying to get all the courts in New
Hampshire to act equally because right
now what's happening to families is it's
a roll of the dice it depends upon which
judge you get and that's not fair to the
family it's not fair to anyone but it is
what is happening and I would not have
believed it if I did not hear it
directly from the judge who said oh no I
don't start that way even though we all
thought they did it's it really is not
the case so how does start
he doesn't he just does what he feels is
right is what he said so there is
nothing that a person can go back and
appeal it or say how this is why we
ended up coming up with well what about
all the Rules of Evidence how do we if I
didn't get awarded 50 50 how do I fight
that there's no way to even fight it but
the bigger situation here and why this
came forward is because
of the way the language is now the
judges are all on different pages when
they approach a new case and this is why
we're trying to get fairness throughout
the courts of New Hampshire and it is it
is not there and I will outright admit I
never expected to hear that it was not
there already I think we all thought it
was and it is not we were told that
right is not happening right but yeah
I'm clear on that I actually this
discussion is done we already made our
decisions
um I'm in opposition to it uh you guys
are in favor of it we'll bring that
we'll bring it out to the full committee
and have and further have this
discussion and vote on it
uh no I don't have uh I got four minutes
left to go through three more uh issues
uh
clear and convincing evidence are we in
agreement that that ought not be in
there
so everybody's okay with that yeah
okay that's what really helps you want
to appeal
and then uh the fit parent we already
agreed on
uh the the current definitions there's a
couple of definitions that we heard and
we're good with that
with with the fit parent or did you want
to Define that more
right basically that's what we're seeing
right correct yeah
yeah uh and I believe
I believe that was it right it was that
other minor change on defining
significant distances and that was in
agreement with parents but just to say
it needs to be significant
um distance away
okay and that's that's in the uh I think
that was in the amendment right yes well
no that was the um that was in the
original the amendment to the amendment
when it came forward oh we reworded it
um to address the concerns that were
brought forward by some of the committee
members
so I would want to see that go in
because I got another that was
representative post Amendment zero five
five one h
is that the one you're referencing
zero seven five eight H and then it was
representative Moulton and I
um we're going to put forward another
amendment
to address
um
B number three
section B number three two B and then
number three
yeah
secondary hang on a minute on on the on
the amendment or on the original bill
we
we were making an amendment on the
amendment Amendment on the amendment
okay B
B3 I don't think yeah I do she wasn't
significant
it was the wording where it said if the
parent works out of town if you look at
number three uh section
B number three and the wording was just
saying if the parent lived out of town
and represent representative Moulton
um and I
we're working to address that concern
that it needs to be a significant
difference for instance if a person
Works in Boston that's really not
we would consider that out of town but
it's not significant and shouldn't
interfere with um parenting time
okay all right so so you and rep Mullen
will be bringing an amendment addressing
B3 yes
okay
um
section three
no that's the one you got it's on the
first page were you right here
yeah uh radiator oh all right
okay
connection
actually does somebody want to consider
bringing this into the full committee it
is that
so we're going to change that three is
that it for something else we're gonna
we're gonna they're bringing an
amendment to address this three right
here
travel you know somebody working out of
state representative long chairman so
would this be something that we would
consider with the whole committee when
we bring forward the other Amendment so
yeah I guess we would do that just take
a picture of it
I I don't like the outside the school
district you taking that out
well we'll discuss that at the full
committee they're bringing they're
bringing an amendment in that will yeah
we don't have the amendment now but is
that the intent of the amendment because
I'm just getting caught up on it
I don't know what you're talking what
you're referring to I'm sorry I'm
looking at I'm just getting caught up
with that number three and it talks
about the school district to be a
disqualifier
oh I didn't see
oh outside of the school district
regions may include yeah so that would
not be a disqualifier it would be up to
the parents to decide
I just
so do you guys want more time on this
today primary because we we have a two
o'clock uh
what on What
306 but at two o'clock I'm supposed to
be in 202. okay okay
okay so we pretty much know does
everybody feel confident we know what's
going to the full committee yeah
yeah okay
representative Bickford the changing to
that wording was
um
one parent lives a significant distance
outside of the child school so it's not
just one town over okay it would have to
be philosophical that's fine yeah and
that's between these are just things
that parents kind of agree upon upon as
why they would have left well I don't
want to give the wrong hint of somebody
like what about the school district
thing well that's what I'm saying so if
that's also if it's within reason that's
the part I'm talking about it would have
to be a reason would be a significant
difference it can't be well one lives in
in Windham and one lives in Salem OR one
lives in Atkinson that's close enough to
get children to school as opposed to one
lives in Salem and one lives up in North
Conway
right that might be a significant
difference and a reason to say we
we might need to make a change on school
nights
do we even need to suggest it so that'll
this will be a discussion we have enough
because we don't have that in front of
us I think it's already in there I know
other than the language that we have in
here you're right
yeah you're right so
uh the way they arrange their time that
they were able to not be in the
but wait that takes them every weekend I
think what they're they're putting it in
here so it can't be used against the
parent and but this is agreement between
the parents as to why
um it might not be 50 50 because of
these reasons
yeah I'm dragging my feet on it but
but this they would be an agreement with
the past it would have to be it would be
right yeah
yeah so the parents will agree
they have to agree that the other ones
and the other one would agree that it's
a significant distance okay so you know
the overnights are out of the questions
for the child
businessman grew oh or reasonings not to
yeah
yeah don't need that okay
yeah maybe you know reasons may include
yeah excited about it
okay any anything else before I adjourn
right okay thank you everybody the uh
subcommittee work session on 185 is
adjourned
Amendment on Section okay so you and
that's right
your your memo will still have
presumption in it right
so uh
I think we had just said the
approximately well
it's a starting point
consumption of
I just can't see
right because everybody is so
understands
yeah you're right it was going to be a
legal presumption it needs to be oh 50
50. it's not approximately 50 50. that's
not going to cost us
that's why we're writing it yeah
it's a mismatch okay well then take out
the word presumption because it's never
going to just say approximately
once we get it through she's got a good
point
at the subcommittee work session on
House Bill
455 and representative toletski was
there something you needed to
let us know where
thank you chairman long I just wanted to
make myself available if they're
questions but um
I thank the committee for having
retained the bill with the hope that we
could have made some fixes to it
um I have been in touch with the
principals who are working on the
problem people from the New Hampshire
legal assistants and some other
immigration attorneys they have been
meeting throughout the summer they feel
they're making progress but we're not at
a place to actually
amend the bill in a way that it's going
to work and we hope that we're going to
be able to come back next year with
something
so I thank you and I apologize for
having to take up your time not not at
all thank you for submitting the bill
yeah
oh so if we don't if you know the the
prime sponsor and if the people the
organizations involved do not feel like
it's time I would just uh move to
recommend that we it all this and look
for better legislation next year so rep
Greg uh
moves to itl
second I second all right
panic
in any discussion on that
CNN
all those in favor of single Bible
saying aye all right all those opposed
name the eyes have it
four to nothing
so that's our recommendation and I'll
adjourn the uh subcommittee on House
Bill 455.
special committee on house bill 306 to
order
and um
actually representative uh Raymond did
you want to
um sure thank you so much you went uh so
I was speaking with the prime sponsor
who's here today and also
um uh former representative The
Honorable Betty gay about
um this bill and their concerns about
the types of uh treatments and programs
I'm using treatments Loosely uh programs
that are fall under the umbrella of
unification therapy and I'd like to
suggest that we consider amending the
bill to add some specif specificity to
what the concerns are that we have
um for what what types of activities
would fall under this umbrella that were
concerned about the judicial grants
utilizing so my suggestion is that on
the original bill on line six we simply
strike through that last line so we keep
the part of the bill that says
um the course you'll give due
consideration to selecting a counselor
who is recommended by the parties and is
a a participating provider in the
party's health insurance period and then
I've had a handout we replaced the last
line with the paragraph that you have in
front of you that says the court shall
not order family communication
treatments programs or services
including but not limited to camps
workshops therapeutic Vacations or
educational programs that as a condition
of enrollment or participation require
or results in any of the following a no
contact order an overnight out of state
or multi-day stay a transfer of physical
or legal custody of the child the use of
private youth Transporters or private
transportation agents engaged in the use
of force threat of force physical
obstruction acutely distressing
circumstances or circumstances that
place the safety of the child at risk or
five the use of threats physical Force
undue coercion verbal abuse isolation
from the child's family community or
other sources of support or other
acutely distressing circumstances and I
think number five really gets to the
Crux of the concerns about some of the
services being provided Under the
Umbrella of reunification therapy that
um I think not just country not just in
New Hampshire But Country ride and even
internationally we're finding that kids
are being subjected to a lot of these
behaviors and it's harming them and so
we want to make sure that when judges
are trying to repair family
relationships that they don't
accidentally stray into making orders
for services that in the end end up
hurting kids
so and I know that the prime sponsor and
honorable buddy uh I'm sorry
um
but again I'm sorry crime shots are
honorable uh that are up of him and
honorable Betty gay are here to talk to
that so
representative is there something uh you
want to add to that or just give us your
sense on this language
yeah I think you're going to come up and
turn on the mic and
I I think we are we are
good hello um Francis Nutter Upham um
Hillsboro 8 Nashua Health and Human
Services
um what was lacking in my original bill
was it clear definition of what
um reunification therapy was
and you've given the definition that you
found that's been used by other states
gives a clear definition of of what
can't happen because uh in the initial
hearing for the bill many people got up
and said well what's wrong with a
therapist trying to put a family back
together and I'm like well no nothing's
wrong with that that's a good idea
um but so then I realized there's like
good reunification therapy and the evil
reunification therapy so we we want to
pass a law against the misuse of
um
court orders
affecting families badly and with
another bill I put in in another
committee
um having courts order families to put
their children in therapy like real
therapy but not on their insurance plan
um makes financial hardship and nor do I
think they have well maybe judges have
rights to do whatever they want I don't
know but none of us would really like it
if someone said well you can't go to the
doctor that's on your plan you have to
pay out of pocket when you have a plan
that should pay for whatever it is that
you need so the having a good definition
the coverage for that whoever the
therapist is
um is a real therapist you know a bona
fide therapist and I'd like to I am a
therapist I'd like to trust that
um
State licensed social workers Mental
Health Counselors licensed clinical
Mental Health Counselors family and
family counselors would not engage in a
destructive kind of therapy as what
we're trying to um
pass a law against
is that clear yeah so um so I'm very
pleased with the amendment thank you
very much
I would like to ask representative
um a question sure thank you for taking
my question uh would you be willing to
add also
um I just learned about forensic
therapists
is there a way we can add this to the
bill so they don't you to the amendment
so they will not be using
that type of therapy can be specifics so
I would have to look up exactly the
parameters of a forensic
therapists
scope of practice and we could just call
Mel Moran because he does that and um
uh he's a former rep and a social work
and I know that
he gets called upon to evaluate a child
or or an adult for a one-time thing
to see if they're going to go into
prison or treatment so I would need to
do a tiny bit of research to know and
then if your understanding of it that
they are doing some kind of therapy then
maybe I wouldn't at all be adverse to
adding that sentences but I just want to
be sure I've defined it correctly
my understanding is that forensic
therapy is just investigative work it's
not really therapy it's just not like
what you mean weekly it's not one-on-one
clinical therapy it's just investigating
what's wrong it's not really treating
the problem that's why
I'm saying to add not to allow forensic
therapy we want to treat the problem if
you're going to have them pay for
treatment we want it to be effective
treatment not just more investigative
work we want clinical work done right
but I suppose we don't want to pass a
law
um preventing someone from doing
forensic research that they need to do
into a family's case this is just about
clinical this this is just fundamental
just so right but what's happening is
my understanding and I the way I
understood it is that some of the
forensic therapists are being
presented as being clinical therapist
and they're not they're just forensic
therapists so I am I'm concerned could
representative Raymond and I do a little
more research on that that would be
awesome thank you in the next 10 minutes
before since we have time to put this
okay thank you thank you for your
concerns yeah they're very valid
representative Greg did you have uh yeah
I was just looking up really quick on
the um forensic psychologist and when
they might be utilized to a forensic
psychologist has a knowledge of not only
um human behavior and stuff but also
within the court so it kind of it's a a
time when say there's
domestic violence or severe accusations
of that that they might use a forensic
therapist to do that not to actually to
perform the therapy but to actually work
within the system as far as
figuring out what to do in a particular
case so I don't I don't see where
they're being used to is like a
therapist you have a particular case or
no I went to a zoom meeting
and they were talking about how forensic
therapists are being promoted as
clinical therapists and that's not what
their job is okay so that would they're
not treating the condition they're just
doing the investigating nor is that
ethical because to treat right
I have a child and her husband are both
psychologists but they are not clinical
psychologists so they would be unethical
for them to treat someone you know
weekly that they ended up being College
professors and um and there's there's a
lot of jobs for that but without a
clinical license to treat people you
can't treat people it's unethical to do
so so let us um look a little further
into the
the hard definition of a forensic
psychologist who can make
recommendations for something but they
don't do clinical treatment so just that
we're sure on that and it may already be
covered but we'll look into it all right
thank you okay representative Greg did
you have yeah just a quick follow-up the
other thing is too I think that we
already covered this only because I know
a forensic psychologist would not be
covered under plans and stuff so by
saying that we cannot have somebody that
is not covered under a plan we're
actually already covering it without
saying it because they can't be charged
so good point good point
I was wondering if anybody had questions
you know I tried to cover everything in
that email
um thank you
thank you well thank you and I'm sorry
any uh further
questions or discussion
sure okay yesterday officials so I
really like how thorough this amendment
is and I think it does speak to the
original uh kind of theme that
representative Nutter Upham was going
for so I really think this strengthens
it and and brings us into something that
we can take to the full committee
foreign
like representative Nutter Upham pointed
out
um we didn't spell out what what
reunification therapy was and in fact
that is really an issue because the
courts use the term
and it it sounds so different from what
it is in practice and the courts use it
and the insurance knows what it is
because they say we won't pay for it so
it's nice to have it spelled out
but that the way they practice it
so any other questions on or questions
on this proposed language
um
so uh yeah it's not an amendment but it
is uh proposed language if if I'll
insane emotion that we all agree with
bringing this proposed language as an
amendment to the full committee
sure okay I make a motion that we all
that we are we going to vote on it that
we all agree that this is good language
to take to the full committee
to amend this bill
and I second it okay so uh
I don't know where to put it on this
paper I get but I'll put it somewhere so
representative Greg what is it 10 30.
and representative uh panic
okay panic
uh on uh proposed language
to be brought in the form of an
amendment by representative uh
uh
uh Raymond
okay
so uh any further discussion
CNN all those in favor saying the Bible
saying aye aye all those opposed the
eyes have it
uh so it's five of us one two three four
five to nothing
um it's called efficiency and uh
can ask just a procedural question sure
I'm showing my novice nature here so
um when I bring this to
um oh well OLS OLS does the entire
committee's name go on it does just my
name does the prime sponsor uh
no yeah they'll make it happen it's
going to be it's going to be a Committee
Member I believe that brings an
amendment forward to the full committee
okay
does she need co-sponsors no okay
you're on your own okay
well this is exciting I've never done
this before and I'm I'm excited that the
um that the committee is in agreement
it's nice when we can all work together
okay
so uh I'll win I'll call the uh
subcommittee work session on House Bill
306 adjourned
thank you